I have personally spent $22,000
studying the greatest copywriting
legends [music] to ever do it. From Gary
Benvvenga to Gary Halpert to John
Carlton to David Oglevie. And over my
last 5 years of mastering the craft of
copywriting, [music] I've run into one
massive issue when it comes to learning
the skill. And that is most of the
greatest copywriting teachings are not
packaged for the modern era.
>> So old. the greatest lessons and
takeaways and fundamentals are packaged
for direct old sales letters or things
that we don't even do in [music] this
modern day.
>> He's got a point.
>> And so what I've done is I've spent the
last few weeks obsessing over everything
I've learned. I've packaged them [music]
into the best lessons you could possibly
have and I've structured them for
modernday simplicity. So, you can
[music] take everything that I'm about
to show you in today's master class and
go from knowing absolutely nothing about
copywriting to being able to walk out of
this training with the confidence that
you can actually get paid for your
writing.
>> I like it a lot.
>> Now, everything that I'm about to show
you, I have a link in the description
below. So, if you want to grab any of
the stuff, the slide deck, the
presentation, go ahead and click the
link down below, put in your email, and
I'll send it directly to you so that way
you can keep it after this training.
Let's dive in because we've got a lot of
stuff to cover. All right, you ready?
So, I've broken this out into seven
simple steps. First, we're actually
going to build a foundation of some of
the greatest copywriting aha moments
I've ever had where throughout my study,
I'm like, "Oh my gosh, that totally
makes sense." So, we're going to dive
through those first just so I can open
up your mind to the world of what it
means to be a copywriter in this year,
in today's age. And then I'm going to
walk you through the seven steps. It's
no trigger, hook, write, structure,
offer, get paid. Okay, those are the
seven stepping stones that I wish I
would have known 5 years ago when
getting started as opposed to just
diving in. I'm like, "Okay, I got to
learn everything about copywriting and
then I had to piece meal it together on
my own." I've already pieced it together
for you in this training. Starting with
the foundation. So, these are the
secrets of copywriting. These are kind
of the aha moments that I've had along
the way that you don't just get by
reading a book. you actually get by
absorbing hundreds of copywriting books
and sales letters and emails and all
those things and you kind of just learn
them along the way. So you guys get to
tap into my thousands of hours of study
and mastering this craft starting with
the new definition of copywriting.
Copywriting, you've probably heard this
if you've studied copywriting at all or
if you haven't, no worries. You've
probably heard the idea that copywriting
is sales in print. This comes from a
copywriting legend named Claude Hopkins.
He is the one that coined the idea that
copywriting is sales in print which is
semi cororrect but again it's an old
definition and it's not comparative to
where we are in today's age. The real
definition of copywriting this year in
this modern era is copywriting is words
that create action. They are persuasive
words that create action. And that
action is not always a sale. That action
could be a click. That action could be
an open. That action could be a sale,
right? It could be an optin. There are
multiple different actions that happen
from the skill of copywriting. In fact,
let me show you some examples of modern
day. Okay? So, modern day could be
YouTube title. The the fact that you
clicked this YouTube video means that
the title that I wrote was
copyrightiting and it persuaded you to
take the action that I wanted you to
take, which is click the video. Okay,
that's copywriting or an email subject
line. You open the email. An article
headline is copywriting. It m it the
action is that you read the essay. A
tweet is copyrightiting because it
persuades you to click someone's
profile. Other things could be a lead
magnet opt-in page could persuade you to
put your email in. All of that stuff is
copyrightiting and you're actually using
it and seeing it more than you think.
And so you have to absorb it that it's
not just some sleazy sales way to make a
bunch of money. It's actually a way that
is embedded throughout all your
business, whether you're a personal
brand or whether you have a
brickandmortar business. And the next
thing in copywriting, you actually don't
create desire for your action. You
channel desire for your action. This
goes back to a copywriting legend named
Eugene Schwarz. He talked about the idea
of channeling desire. People already
actually have desires in their heart to
do something. And when you are writing
copy, when you are writing words that
create action, all you are doing is
actually channeling their existing
desires into the action you want them to
take. So if I want you to opt into my
email list, I may tell you, "Hey, click
the link in the description below to get
this copywriting training for free."
Well, that training is something you
already want. you already want to learn
copywriting and so I'm channeling your
desire to learn copywriting towards the
action that I want you to take which is
opting into my email list. Right? So
that is channeling desire you already
have. It goes for anything. It could be
weight loss. It could be relationships.
It could be making money. Right? You are
taking people's already human innate
desires and saying how can I move their
existing desire into my product that
solves that desire that gives them that
desire. You don't create desire inside
of people. Okay. The next thing is
copywriting
in this day and age is no longer a
career. Now when I look back at it, Gary
Ben Svena, Gary Halper, all of these
guys had a career in copywriting. They
were copywriters. that does not exist
anymore. And this is from a
self-proclaimed copywriter. Okay? I
write copy for a living. But I don't
portray myself as a copywriter because
it is actually more of a meta skill than
it is an actual career. Nobody wants a
copywriter. They want the end result of
a copywriter. They want the skill of
copywriting attached to a more
resultsdriven medium. For example, like
I run a personal brand as a creator. I'm
a creator, right? And so I see myself as
a creator, as a publishing company, as a
media empire, whatever you want to see.
Those are the ways that I actually see
my business. And copywriting is one of
the main levers that I use to grow my
business. So I'll use it to write videos
like this. I'll use it to write emails,
to make products, to make offers. And
those things create the empire that is
my business. But I am still a creator.
Right? You are not a copywriter. You
don't have to be a copyriter. The other
one is like a company. You may be a
business owner running a company, but
your job is to use copy to create ads,
build funnels, build campaigns that make
you more money, that increase your
rorowass, like all of those things. You
don't have to be a copywriter. This this
is a skill for you to leverage, not
necessarily an identity for you to
encapsulate. The next thing is the
measuring the success of copywriting.
Right? It could get very dicey when you
start thinking of all the metrics, open
rates and clickthrough rates and all
this stuff and you start ma uh you start
trying to understand is my writing any
good. Am I any good at this
copyrightiting thing? And it took me too
long to realize well did the people you
want take the action you wanted them to
take. That is the only thing you're
measuring. So whenever you're writing
copy, what is the thing you're trying to
measure? Sales is probably the biggest
one. Did they buy my product? So, the
copy that I wrote, did they buy my
product? Or if you're writing uh YouTube
thumbnails and headlines, how is the
click-through rate? Did they click the
video? Meaning, was the copy good enough
to persuade them to click? Did they open
my email? Okay, was my hook good enough
to get them to open? That is the only
thing you're measuring is when you write
copy, you are measuring the one action
tied to that copy to determine whether
it was successful or not successful. If
it was below industry standards or your
own standards, then you need to increase
your copywriting skill to be able to
increase the output of that. If it was
high, fantastic. You know, you've got a
banger on your hands and you can reuse
it a little bit later. But to measure
successful copywriting, you are going to
measure the one action that the copy you
wrote persuaded those people to do. The
next little aha moment is the talk
framework. So, target offer copy. This
is actually something that most sales
marketing, all these gurus online
actually get backwards. They'll talk
about the power of the actual writing
and the copy themselves, especially
copyriters. They'll tout copywriting all
day long. They'll be like, "Oh, it's the
best thing since sliced bread." But what
I have learned goes back to a rule from
uh from a legendary marketer named Ed
Mayer. He called it the 40420 rule. 40%
of your copywriting success is actually
based on the people viewing or reading
the copy. The other 40% is based on the
offer and the last 20% is based on your
copy in that order. Meaning, if you can
write something that gets in front of
the right people that makes them an
irresistible offer, you are 80% of the
way to a grand slam success in whatever
you're trying to sell, open, click, bait
people into. Okay? And that's okay,
right? That's a very good thing.
Meaning, you could write really mediocre
copy, but if your offer and your target
audience is dialed in, you will win.
Hands down, you will win. On the flip
side, you could write really incredible
copy, but if your offer sucks and your
target audience is not dialed in, your
copy will tank. It's just the way it
works. And so when we start talking
about audience and people and
understanding the mindset and the
mastery and the psychology and the offer
creation, when we talk about those
things inside of this copywriting master
class, I need you to understand that
that's why they are that important
because you can write sexy words all day
long and it won't help you one bit if
you don't know your target audience and
if you don't know how to create an offer
that is persuasive to them. The
copywriting is just the cherry on top
that will amplify your success which is
a perfect transition into step one
knowing our target audience. This is the
most important step for copywriting.
It's the most important step for human
living. You have to understand the
psychology of humans because humans are
buyers. They are the people that are
investing into your lifestyle. These are
the people that are buying your
products, opting into your email list,
watching your videos. And if you don't
understand who those people are, what
makes them tick, what makes them happy,
what makes them sad, if you don't
understand this kind of ecosystem, then
you can't write copy. No one cares about
you. They care about themselves. And so,
you have to tap into a world where you
understand them more than you even
understand yourself. And the three ways
to understand your market at the highest
level are this. You can either be the
market, which is the number one way I
highly recommend people focus on this
being the market. You could be a secret
shopper, or you can have coffee in their
world. Let's dive into each one of
those. I'm going to make it so easy for
you. The first thing is be the market. I
hear this all the time. I coach
copywriters. I have a club full of
copywriters. I hear this all the time
where they're like, "I want to write to
coaches and founders. I want to write to
gym bros. I want to write to golfers."
And I say, "Well, are you a golfer? Are
you a gym bro? Are you a founder?
Because if you're not, you're going to
struggle to write to those people
because there are things that those
people go through that they navigate in
their head that they never say out loud,
that they'll never put on a Facebook
post, that they'll never write on a
survey. They'll never say those things.
You only know them by being the market.
I know this because I sell a lot in the
golf niche. I've sold a lot in the golf
niche. And the best way that I've
increased my sales was by going playing
golf. I would go out there and I would
play golf. I would hit my driver and it
would go to the right. And I'm like,
what does that mean when it goes to the
right? It's like, oh, it means it's a
slice. Oh, well, how do I fix that? And
I try and fix that. I realize 99% of
golfers have that problem. Or if I want
to write to the gym, bros, I go to the
gym and I'm like, gosh, man, I'm really
nervous in here. Why am I so anxious? I
I don't know what I'm doing in here. I
have all this anxiety. I I don't know
what weights to lift and things. And I
just left and I would leave and I just
go run instead. And then I realized, oh
my goodness, gym anxiety is a real
thing. and people don't know what
they're doing. So, how am I supposed to
sell a gym membership to all these new
gym people who want to get in shape, but
they have all this anxiety? Well, now I
can write an email that talks about the
anxiety of going to the gym. That is not
something gym bros will say. You
experience that by being the market. So,
the more you are the market for the
people that you are trying to serve, the
better you can serve them, the more
problems you can solve, the more
products you can sell. And one of the
best ways to do this is actually write
to your own self a couple years back.
Like let's say I wrote to myself who was
starting to be a golfer just two years
ago. Well, I can think well what
problems was I going through then and
now I can write how I've solved those
problems, how I've overcome those
things. That is going to be an
increasingly powerful thing for you to
continue to write. So you want to sell
and write towards the people whose
market you are a part of. The next one
is to be a secret shopper. You can go
look at other people who are selling
things to the people that you want to
sell things to. They could be creators
who have a big influence in the market.
So, they have a big YouTube channel or
an email newsletter that has a bunch of
subscribers for the people that you want
to serve. Go down the rabbit hole of
those brands. Go figure out what YouTube
videos have made that are doing really
well. What ads have they created that
are doing really, really well? what
products are they selling all the way
down to what words do they use? Like
what pains and bleeding neck problems
are they actually triggering inside of
their readers. So like if you go in the
copywriting world for 2 seconds, you
could go browse a bunch of copywriters
who are selling products and you could
see that almost every one of them sells
some sort of client acquisition product.
Here's how to get clients 101. Like
everybody sells a product like that. And
when you see five, six, seven people in
your niche selling the same product over
and over and over again, that is a
secret shopper identity where you're
like, okay, obviously this is a big
problem for copywriters. Obviously, this
is something that they buy a lot or
otherwise not everybody would be doing
it. Use those trends to your advantage.
Another thing that I like to do is I
like to go to YouTube channels and on
their videos, I click the most popular
videos and I try and see what has gotten
the most clicks and views. That tells me
there is a big desire for that sort of
topic. Do that with five, six, seven
creators and you start to understand
what are big topics in that niche.
Again, if you go in the golf niche, you
could go to five, six, seven creators in
the golf niche and you could see it's
the same four, five types of videos,
types of problems that they solve over
and over and over again. The best thing
that you could do as a secret shopper is
to actually opt in and buy some of these
products from these people and and see
their entire funnel. What do their
upsells look like? Their downells, what
do their emails sound like? What does
the sales page sound like? And you could
get their customer service experience,
see what you like, what you don't like,
and so you could better understand as
somebody entering the market, is this
helpful? Is this inspiring? What did
these people miss? What did these people
absolutely nail? What can you do to
adapt their sales process, their
funnels, their words to actually make
them better for your market so you can
outsell them? And the last one for
knowing your market is to have coffee in
their world. Get an espresso. Go hang
out in Reddit threads. Go hang out in
YouTube comments. Go hang out in
Facebook groups. There is a certain
language that comes with any niche that
you want to sell to, that you want to
write for, whether it's it or golf or
skateboarding or selling honey or
anything like that. Like for me, if I
were to read something online and
somebody were to try and sell me a
course on hitting their irons, well, I
would know they're not a golfer because
you would actually say, "You want to
pure your irons." You don't say, "I want
to putt well." You want to say, "I want
to read the greens." You want to use the
language and the words that your market
uses when you're having coffee with
them. When you understand the ecosystem
that they talk in, you have to be able
to understand the way they think about
their problems and the words they use to
name those problems. Because when you
can use their language and you can
understand how they talk, you will
better know how they will respond to
your words. A great story about knowing
your people comes from the legendary
Gary Halper who was one of the highest
paid copywriters to ever live. He passed
away in 2008, but he has this story
where he was in a room in California
writing with another very legendary
copywriter named John Carlton. John
wrote a sales letter to sell that sort
of product and he passed it over to Gary
and he said, "Gary, can you take a look
at this?" And he responded with, "Have
some gosh freaking empathy." That's all.
and he threw the sales letter back to
him. And what he was saying, I said it
the nice way, but he was saying, "You
need to care about these people." One of
the best market research tactics, one of
the best investments that you can do
into knowing your market is actually
give a crap about the people that you
write for. Right now, I'm talking to you
as a copywriters because I care about
people who want to write. I care about
people who want to make a living writing
online. I care about people who want to
have autonomy over their lives without
working a nineto-ive measly job in a
cubicle. These are the people that I
care about. And because I care about it,
I make stuff like this. I spend a lot of
time investing and creating training
that's free online that you could
capture to change your life because I
care about you. If you don't care about
the people that you're selling to, they
will sniff that out immediately. They
will sniff out that this guy's just
trying to make money off us. This is why
half the AI bros online creating AI
tools and AI trainings and things like
that don't actually sell anything
because people know you're just trying
to get rich off of me. You don't
actually care about solving my problems.
But the people who are creating products
and who actually care about their market
are able to have an empathetic point of
view. They're able to sell emotionally,
not just logistically, which we will
unpack a little bit more later. Now,
let's talk about what do you actually
need to know about your market? Because
do you really need to know their
political views or where they sleep at
night or where they live? Sure, you can.
But there are really just five things
that you need to fully understand about
your market at the highest level. And
I'm going to show you the two layer
tactic that I use to understand my
target audience at a level that 99% of
marketers and copywriters actually never
get to. Okay. Now, the five things that
you need to understand are right here on
the screen. Desires, pains, dreams,
fears, obstacles. So let's break down
what each of those are and how you
figure them out. All right, so first is
desires. Desire is different from a
dream. They may sound similar, but a
desire is what do you want today? What
is something that you want today? Like
for example, the copywriting market. If
I were talking to copywriters, I think,
well, what do you want today? They say,
I want clients. I want to work for
myself. I want to fire my boss. I want
to freelance. I want to master this
skill at a high level so I can make a
lot of money. Okay, those are desires.
What do you want today? The other things
are pains. What keeps them up at night?
Again, back to copywriters. What is a
pain? Well, a pain is I'm not selling
enough. I'm having a hard time finding
clients. It's typically the opposite of
their desires. There's something that's
stopping them from getting those
desires. That's going to come a little
bit later with obstacles. And then
dreams. dreams is bigger picture. What
is what is it that you want in the
future? Well, the future is I want full
autonomy. I want to be able to work for
myself. I want to be able to write the
stuff that I want to write or I want to
be able to provide for my family and not
have financial concerns. I want to have
six months of savings in my bank
account. Those are future dreams that
they have. Now, we're starting to
unpack. And then we have fears. What are
they scared of? What are they scared of?
And it's those pains amplified in a
future sense. Well, I'm scared of being
broke. I'm scared of opening up my bank
account. There's nothing in there and I
don't know how I'm going to pay the
bills. I'm scared of having to live in
some cubicle for the rest of my life
working for some Joe Schmo who has no
idea what he's doing, but he pays the
bills and so I got to be here. Right?
That you see how I'm tapping into this,
right? And then obstacles. What's
stopping them from getting there? Well,
what's stopping them is it's hard to
find quality training on copywriting
like this uh at an affordable price or
it's hard to understand what's worth
chasing or what's not worth chasing. Or
what's stopping them is that every week
they get a new flavor of the week.
Should I be an AI? Should I sell golf
stuff? Should I uh create my own
personal brand? Should I start an email
newsletter? Should I start a school
community? And they're just information
overload and they don't actually know
what to pursue and what to put their
time in. or if they failed the obstacles
that I failed time and time again and
and I don't have the motivation to start
a new thing. Right? So, there's there's
these five layers to what you need to
know about your market. I'm going to
show you how to find them. But there's a
secret. There's actually two [snorts]
layers of each one of these emotions
that they go through. Okay? There's a
surface layer, the thing that they say,
and then there's the deep layer, the
thing they won't say. All right? You can
really only get this by being the market
uh at the highest level. So, think about
this. When when a copyriter says, "I
want more clients." What they're
actually saying is, "I want to stop
worrying about money and feel in control
of my life." You see the difference?
They're saying, "I want more clients."
That's not what they want. That's not
what they want. They think clients is
the path to not worrying about money and
feeling more control. When they say,
"Uh, I'm not getting results. I I bought
that. I'm not getting results." What
they're what they're saying is, "I'm
scared that I'm wasting my life on the
wrong path. I'm scared that this isn't
the right thing for me. I'm scared that
learning this skill is a useless waste
of my time." That's what they're
actually saying. And so, you have to
understand what is it that these people
are saying, but what is the layer deeper
beyond that, right? Amateurs are the
ones that write to the sur, I'm going to
help you get more clients, blah blah
blah. But pros are the ones that
understand the deeper layer. Hey, I can
help you find control of your time, your
life, and your systems so that way you
never have to worry about money ever
again. Which one resonates more? You see
the difference? There's a surface level
and a deep level. And you have to
understand those emotions at the highest
level. And the way to reflect those
emotions to them is by saying exactly
what I said a little bit earlier. You
want to steal their own words. Okay?
Steal their own words. the exact phrases
that they're saying about their pains,
about their hopes, about their desires,
about their obstacles. You want to steal
those exact words. And but one of the
secret ways of stealing those exact
words is when you are the market and you
say those words in your head. That is
stealing the market's words on the deep
layer. Nobody's going to tell you that.
Nobody's telling you that. But I'm
telling you, that's a secret little gem,
little secret sauce. When you become the
market, you say things in your own head
that you can swipe for your own copy.
You can use those words in your titles,
your YouTube titles, your email subject
lines, your thumbnails, your bullets,
your sales copies, your headlines, all
of that sort of stuff. Is that when
you're secretly saying those words to
yourself about those problems, those
fears, those obstacles, because you are
the market, you write those things down.
You say, "Okay, well, how do I solve
this? And once I solve this, how do I
sell this?" Right? Solved and sell.
Solved and sell. The next thing that
will help you tremendously is by using
my AI market research prompts. Okay, I
put a link in the description below. It
is five prompts. It is five massive
prompts that me and my good friend Ben
Fidman put together when we were running
our marketing agency together. And we
would use this to go dig up Reddit
threads and YouTube comments and
Facebook groups and all this stuff. So
that way you can actually use the words
of the market based on what they're
writing themselves. And it's even broken
down into pains, desires, dreams, hopes,
obstacles, all the things that I tell
you, it already breaks it down for you.
So, if you want the lazy man's 15minute
way to do all this market research, I
would say go ahead and grab that. And
then when you have that and you go be
the market, you go play golf, you go
sell honey, you go do whatever it is
that you want to do, you could use that
to help guide you. But that is the
quick, fast, easy, dirty way to start
getting to know your market as quickly
as possible. All right, moving on to
step two, which is trigger. And by the
way, if you are enjoying this, please
like and subscribe uh to the channel on
this video. It tells YouTube that this
is incredibly valuable and that you want
me to continue to pour out more free
value like this. What does trigger mean?
Trigger means that there is some sort of
emotional trigger inside of the people
that you are trying to serve. If you
clock it just right, it will make them
pay attention to what you are saying. If
you do not trigger someone, then they
won't read. They will not slide down
your copy. They won't read your article.
They won't click your video. It doesn't
matter. You have to trigger someone
emotionally. In fact, it looks like
this. There's really this sliding scale
between like a negative sort of emotion,
lukewarm, and a positive emotion. Like I
like to think of it like anger and
excitement are on the opposite side of
scales. If I make someone really angry,
frustrated, sad, depressed, insert your
negative emotion of choice. If I can
really pull the trigger on that, chances
are they're going to click, listen,
read, buy, all those things. I know that
sounds counterintuitive, like you might
be, why would they buy if you piss them
off? I promise you, any sort of emotion
will get someone fired up to take a next
step action with you. On the opposite
side is the positive emotion like
excitement, joy, elation, uh like
desire, like on the highest scale like,
"Oh my goodness, I cannot wait to dive
into what this looks like." Right?
Excitement. In the middle is lukewarm.
This is where most people, they just
play it safe. They don't want to piss
anyone off. They don't want to
overpromise. They don't want to do this
thing. And what happens is you create
this lukewarm
um writing, this lukewarm attention, not
grabbing stuff that no one cares about.
And if you get someone lukewarm, it's
very much like in the Bible how it says
like, uh, I will spit the lukewarm out
of my mouth in the book of Revelation.
Have you not read that? You should read
that. It's incredible. It's already
written in there that people are the
same way that if you get lukewarm, you
will make zero action. You will get no
clicks. You will get no sales. So, you
have to understand how to emotionally
trigger someone. That's not a bad thing.
That's a good thing. You want to find
the emotion that you're going to trigger
in someone and then do it. If you do not
emotionally trigger them, they won't
click. They won't buy. They won't give
you attention at all. Now, I'm going to
show you the emotions to trigger in in
people that actually mean the most to
them and how to do it because people buy
emotionally, but they justify
logistically. Here's what I mean.
Somebody's going to buy your product
because they feel like you gave them
hope, like there's an opportunity for
them to solve this huge problem and they
just filled with hope. But when they go
tell their wife that they spent $4.99 on
your course, they're not going to be
like, "I bought it because it gave me
hope and I just feel like I've lost hope
lately, but this course gave me hope.
This training gave me hope. This
community gave me hope." Right? They're
not going to say that. They're going to
go to their wife and be like, "It was on
sale. It was 50% off." And you think
they bought it cuz it was on sale.
That's not why they bought it. They
bought it because you triggered them.
You triggered an emotion and that
emotion stuck. People remember emotions.
They don't remember sales. They don't
remember how much they bought stuff for.
They remember how you made them feel.
Okay? And so, let me walk you through uh
what is called the life force eight.
This comes from copywriter Drew Whitman.
He wrote the book cash advertising. And
in cashising, he writes the eight
scientifically backed and researched
emotions that people have the highest
desire for fulfilling. Right? This is
the greatest triggers that you can give
to someone. Okay? So it goes down from
first is survival, enjoyment of life,
life extension. So this is like health
and wealth. This is why health, wealth,
and relationships are always and have
always been the highest selling things.
So if you're selling supplements, that's
life extension, right? If you're selling
enjoyment of life, right? It even could
be autonomy, enjoying having a bigger
house, having a nicer car, uh having
status, right? And we'll talk more about
that in a minute. But in that sense,
that survival, that status, those sorts
of things are the number one thing.
People want to feel like they will make
it tomorrow. They will thrive. Okay?
They want to know that they're not going
to open up their bank account and
nothing's in there. That's why the
money-making niche has always been very
profitable because people need to
survive. The next one is enjoyment of
food and beverages. People want to enjoy
uh great food, great beverages. It also
kind of ties into uh the survival
methodology, right? Uh freedom from
fear, pain, and danger. If you can help
someone uh move away from their fears,
from their dangers, from their pains,
you will increase the sales. That is a
big sales motivator. Like if you're
selling real estate houses, one of
them's in a bad neighborhood, but it's a
much nicer house. The other one is in a
great neighborhood, but it's a much
smaller, not as nice house, you will
easily sell the one that's in a better
neighborhood because people want to move
away from fear and danger. Say, "Hey,
this house is much nicer, but you might
get mugged here." Right? This house is
not as nice and it costs more. uh but
the neighborhood is much nicer and
you'll be much safer. That's the one
you're going to sell. Do you see the
dichotomy of the emotions that people
are buying in that? The next one is
sexual companionship, meaning
relationships. People want to have good
relationships uh with spouses, with
significant others. They want to have
those things comfortable living
conditions. Again, goes back to the
status survival. Uh number six, this is
all status to be superior, to keep
winning. This is why BMW, Rolex,
Mercedes, they those things will never
go out of style. Yeezy. Having status is
actually the number one way to show
other people the number ones, right?
Survival, life, enjoyment. When you have
status, that is your way of displaying
that. So, like I was talking to somebody
in my club earlier and they were like,
Allan, how do I sell sneakers in an
emotional way? Play into the status.
Play into the status that those sneakers
give them. Play into the status that
wearing a nice watch gives you. You play
into status. And that status is a
demonstration of the emotions why they
bought it. Number seven. Number eight,
care of protection and loved ones.
Social approval, right? Which is why
status is a big one. All of these are
reasons that you should inject into your
copy. One of the you don't have to
inject all of them, but picking one of
these emotions is a specific reason that
will p that will make someone want to
click what you're selling, understand
it, opt into your list, care about what
you're writing. And once you understand
the emotion that people want and the
emotion that triggers them to buy, okay,
then you can understand the
transformation of that emotion, right?
So here's a couple examples right here.
Like if you are selling a mattress,
okay, think about the emotion of what
the mattress is doing from them and the
transformation that that emotion gives
them. All right, so watch this. So if
I'm buying a mattress there, I'm not
buying a 100% cotton soft mattress.
That's not what I'm selling. What I'm
actually selling is the best sleep of
your life. You're going to feel so
relaxed. You're going to feel
incredible. You're going to wake up with
tons of energy. That's what you're
selling. Do you see how that is
emotionally charged? Do you see how I'm
focusing on the transformation and not
the feature of the mattress itself? I'm
not talking about made in America, 100%
cotton, softest mattress ever. I'm
talking about best sleep of your life.
Okay. The other one, like a course. I'm
not trying to sell you a course or a
training. I'm trying to sell you a
version that you have got this figured
out. I'm not trying to sell you a 2-hour
copywriting thing. I'm trying to sell
you the idea that by the end of this
thing, you will understand this big
obstacle of copyrightiting that you've
never understood before. You're finally
going to walk away and you're going to
be like, I get it and I've got this
skill and this skill is going to help me
make money. There's a transformation to
what you are selling now. Out of all of
the emotional desires, out of all of the
transformation, I'm going to go back to
fear beats desire. Think about this.
People will buy to solve their pain
faster than they will buy to prevent
pain. So, for example, there's a product
in the health and wellness space called
AG1. It is one of the most popular
products in the world. It's a $97 a
month supplement subscription. What it
does is it helps you prevent the problem
of not getting your nutrients right. It
is a preventative maintenance type
thing. And it is huge. It is absolutely
huge. But do you know what's bigger by
like a bajillion? Right now there's
something called GLP1s that is selling
and it helps people lose weight. Okay,
that infinitely exploded way past AG1
with very little marketing, right? They
market now. They're they're marketing
heavy, but GLP1s are all over the place.
Why? Because GLP1s is a painkiller, not
a preventative maintenance. People's
fear of being overweight and bullied and
dying because they're overweight
overcomes the desire to stay in shape or
get all their nutrients and all this
stuff. People's fear and their pain will
forever
outsell their desire and a promise. So,
whenever you're writing copy, you have
to understand what is their biggest
fear, what is their biggest pain, how
does this actually help them solve that
problem for them. that will dramatically
increase the response, the emotional
response that people have to the words
that you write. Here's a visual
representation of what that looks like.
And I'm actually going to show you how
to write a story that uh that
exemplifies this visual representation.
But you see this, okay, so right now
your reader is in a tree. That tree is
on fire. That means your reader is going
through some sort of fear. Oh my god,
this tree is going to burn down and I'm
going to die. Some sort of pain. Oh my
god, I'm stuck in this tree and it's on
fire. and your product is the thing that
helps them get out of the tree. You're
the guy that's bringing it down. You're
like, "Hey, looks like you're in a tree
that's on fire and I have a metal
ladder. Would you like to use this
ladder to get out of that burning tree?"
And they say, "Oh my god, you're the
best ever. How much is the ladder?" And
you're like, "It's 97 bucks onetime
payment or it's uh $33 a month for three
months." And you're like, "Oh my god,
I'll pay $97 right now." And you're
like, "Boom, sold." And you put the
ladder in the tree and they buy it. They
buy it because they're in a tree and
it's on fire and you're selling them a
ladder to get out of the tree. That is
what I mean by fear beats desire.
Imagine if this person were in a tree
and the tree was not on fire and you're
like, "Hey man, eventually that tree is
going to cause some problems. It's going
to rot. It's going to fall down. It's a
old tree. Uh, in fact, it might even
catch on fire. Uh, because there's a lot
of just like small fires in these
forests and you know, it's really dry
over here. if you want, I could sell you
this $97 ladder so that way you're safe
in the future. How many people are going
to buy that? They're going to be sitting
in the tree. They're gonna be like, "Ah,
that's cool. I appreciate it. No, I'm
good. I'm good. Thank you, though."
Right? There's no emotion in that. I
didn't trigger someone. And so, they're
not going to want to buy what you're
selling because they don't understand
the fear and the pain that you're trying
to save them out of because you didn't
trigger the right emotions. Now, the
next thing that we need to dive into is
not just emotional triggers, but
persuasion triggers. So on top of
emotional triggers and understanding
what actually makes them click buy and
and spend time in your world is you have
to understand the persuasion triggers
that increase their desire to buy from
you to opt into you to say yes to the
bait that you are trying to get them to
bite. Now these are very tactical and
you can inject these into any sort of
copywriting and sales process that
you're doing. The six that I have on the
screen are the most powerful that I've
ever seen and ever affected. First one
is curiosity. Then you have proof of
value, story, urgency and scarcity,
honesty, and authority. Now, let's walk
through what these look like. Okay,
let's walk through what these look like.
Proof of value is proof that what you're
selling actually works. It it reverses
the risk of what they think is a problem
with your product. So, if I come in here
and I say and I write something that
says $697
a month value for less than the cost of
two books on Amazon, that could be uh
something to sell one of my communities.
is I have a copywriting community called
Copy Creator Club. And every month I
drop about $700 worth of resources
inside of that club, but it costs 50
bucks a month. Well, two books on Amazon
are 25 bucks uh each. And so those two
books on Amazon 50 bucks a month. I'm
delivering $700 worth of value for two
Amazon books. Do you see the proof of
value in that stack? And I can justify
that proof with the actual retail prices
of the things that dropped in the course
and stuff like that. When you're looking
at something like that, you see that and
you're like, "Oh my goodness. Wow, that
is ins that is insane value." So, you
get people more persuaded because of the
proof of value. The next one is urgency
or scarcity. A lot of people think that
deadlines with an urgency deadlines like
this code expires on this date or we
only have 10 left or anything like that.
Pe a lot of people think that's sleazy.
If you're not lying about it, it's
actually generous. And the reason that a
deadline is generous is because humans
are very indecisive. Humans are
indecisive. They're like, "Oh, should I
buy this? Should I not buy? I don't
know." And what happens is at the end of
the deadline, they either bought it or
they didn't. They either opted in or
they didn't. And either one is fine, but
you made them make a decision. And that
forcing of making them make a decision
will either increase their regret that
they didn't get it or will increase
their happiness that they did get it.
And so next time that you do a deadline,
next time that you do an offer of some
sort, they will think back and say, "Oh
yeah, I got that and it was totally
worth the money." Or, "Yeah, ah man, I
didn't get that and I kind of regretted
it because, you know, my other buddy got
it, but uh he loved it and and I didn't
get it, which kind of sucked." And so a
deadline forces them to make a decision
by a specific date. Whether it is a
deadline for a price discount, deadline
for a price increase, or a deadline for
price bonuses, it is absolutely
significantly more persuasive to have
some sort of scarcity, fear of missing
out. Remember, emotional trigger, fear,
urgency, and scarcity do that. The next
one is honesty. Okay, this is very rare
in the marketing world. But being honest
about what you are trying to do is
actually very persuasive. Like for
example, if I were to try and sell a
bunch of books, right, from my library
and let's say I were to sell them half
off. Having honesty and a reason why I'm
selling them half off is going to
increase my sales tremendously as
opposed to me saying, "Hey, I'm selling
off my library and it's 50% off." What
if I said, "Hey, I'm selling off my
library and it's 50% off because I
dropped half the books when I was moving
to my house. So now a lot of them are
damaged, but the words are fantastic.
They're still in very solid condition,
but I did drop them. Think about that.
Which one are you more persuaded to buy?
Well, you're more persuaded to buy the
one where I dropped the books and it's
Btock Books and and they're still
fantastic condition, but I did. They're
not in the most perfect condition, so
that's why they're 50% off. That is
honesty. That increases the
believability. And when people believe
you, they will buy from you. The next
thing is story. I'm going to show you
one of the most persuasive story
structures you could possibly use to
sell anything to anyone, okay? Any
product, any email newsletter, uh any
tweet, anything like that. Let me show
you this exact structure that I've used
a billion times. Okay? So, check this
out. This is actually called the hero's
journey structure. It's actually a much
more simplified version of this, but let
me show you what that looks like. So
basically what it looks like is you have
a character and the character is
typically your reader. That is your
reader. They are in a tree and the tree
is their world. Okay? It's their current
circumstances. They're hanging out in
this tree. Life is good. It's not too
bad. It's not great. It's not bad. But
they're just navigating their current
world, what it's like. And they want to
move beyond the current world. And
they're just thinking, they're
pondering. They haven't done anything
yet. And then one day something bad
happens to your character. Okay? They're
in the tree and the tree catches on
fire, meaning they had maybe a close
relative pass away or they got hurt in a
car accident or they are completely
broke and they have to pay all the bills
or they realized how overweight they are
and it's causing a lot of health
problems. Something bad happens. That's
a fire. Okay? And in that tree, they're
in a fire. You are a helper. You are
this guide. You are their Yoda. you are
their Gandalf and you come in and you
talk to the person in the tree and you
understand the person in the tree and
it's like, "Hey man, I see you're in
this tree and that it's on fire and that
you're going through this really rough
divorce or that man, you're you're not
looking so in shape and it feels like
you're probably having health problems.
I could probably help you solve those
health problems." You say, "Can I help
you?" Right? You are the helper where
you see these people in a tree and you
bring something with you. That ladder is
your product. Remember this slide from a
little bit earlier? your reader is more
willing to buy your product when you as
a helper are willing to guide them
towards that product. So in the helper
phase, this is typically where like
writing social media content and emails
and things like that is your persuasive
copy because it's where you build a
relationship with the reader. The reader
sees you as the helper and you're like,
"Hey dude, I've been there, done that.
I've solved this problem. I know exactly
what you're going through." And they're
like, "Hey man, uh that's awesome. Can
you help me out of this tree?" and
you're like, "Absolutely, I could help
you out of this tree. Here is a product
to help you do that." Right? Whether
it's my coaching or my community or this
training or whatever it is. And they
say, "Man, thank you so so much." And so
the phases are this are again your
character, normal day, normal life,
normal circumstances, fire. Oh my
goodness. I'm having a complete
meltdown. Fear and pain increases. And
then you're the guy that says, "I
understand that fear and pain. I know
exactly what you're going through. I can
help you out of that." And they're like,
"How?" and you say, "Here, this is how
you get out of that." And they say,
"Perfect. How much to get out of that?"
You say, " $97." That story structure
I've used time and time and time and
time again. You can implement that
anywhere. Now, if you want an extra
resource to kind of help you, and I told
you I'd give you some free gifts along
the way, is that I go way more into
storytelling structures and triggers and
things like that in my 42 advanced
copywriting secrets. Way more than we're
going to be able to dive into today
because we've got a lot of other stuff
we have to cover. But I did go ahead and
put a link in the description below to
help you understand the psychology that
A-list copywriters use to create more
emotional and persuasive triggers in
their readers to get them to listen,
click, buy, and engage. Next, we're
going to talk about step three, which is
the hook. The hook is the thing that
captures their attention. So, we
understand the psychological triggers,
the emotions. We understand our market,
but we have to be able to say the thing
we want to say in a way that gets them
to stop the scroll, that gets them to
open the email, that gets them to read
the letter. We have to be good at hooks.
In fact, David Oggovy said that 80% of
your readers will only read the hook.
Four out of five people who engage with
your tweet, your email, your sales
letter, your article, your YouTube
video, they will only read the hook and
decide right then and there, should I
click this? Should I buy this? Should I
read this? Right? You watching this
YouTube video are one of the people that
decided to click and and engage with the
hook because the hook was good enough.
But if the hook sucked, you would have
kept scrolling to another video. You
would have read a different essay. You
would have read a different sales
article. You are in competition with
everyone else trying to capture their
attention. You have to win the war of
attention. Our economy's ecosystem, our
economy's currency. We spend money in
attention. If you cannot get attention,
you will never have money. And so, you
need to make them stop. Okay? There are
10,000 other things begging for their
attention. Tik Tok, Netflix, all that
stuff. So, you have to write hooks so
good, so persuasive that they stop and
they say, "Bam, I want some of that."
And I'm going to show you exactly how to
do that. I can't believe I'm giving all
this away. This is sauce. This is sauce
right here. All right. The first concept
that you need to understand is that the
job of a hook is to get them to read the
next sentence. It's not to sell the
click. It's not to sell any of that
stuff. The job is to get them curious
enough to read the next sentence. If I
get you to read the hook of my YouTube
video, the job is that I'm curious
enough to see what he says next. If if
you read the hook of a tweet, you say,
"I'm curious enough to see what the next
line is." All of that. That is the only
job of the hook. You're not trying to
sell anything. Okay? So, you have to
picture your reader, I love doing this,
is is you have to picture your reader on
the couch. He's on the couch and he's
eating steak tacos. He's got an ice cold
beer right there and he's got the game
on and he's just watching it and he's
chilling it. and he gets a notification
from his phone and he picks up his phone
and it's your tweet or it's your
article, it's your email, it's your
YouTube video. Ding, ding. And it pops
up. Would that person stop with the
taco? Would they put the taco down?
Would he put his beer to the side? He'd
pause the game and click your YouTube
video, click your article. Would he do
that? Would she do that? If the answer
is no, your hook sucks. If the answer is
yes, then you have a dynamic hook
because you've tapped into the emotion.
You've tapped into the desire. And I'm
going to show you how to write these
dynamic hooks that pass the couch test.
All right. The seven elements of a
killer hook that get them to stop right
what they're doing is curiosity, pain,
promise, specificity, simplicity, proof,
time frame. Those are the seven. I'm
going to show you how to use them. All
right? So, you can get these down. The
first one is curiosity. You have to open
a curiosity loop. This is by far the
most important way to get someone's hook
attention. It's it's the most important
way to get them to stop what they're
doing and be like, I got to figure out
what this person is saying. Now, let's
say I wrote a hook to copyriters because
I know my audience. Who am I talking to?
Talking to copywriters. So, I'm going to
write a hook for copywriters. Am I
writing a hook for everyone? No. I'm
writing a hook for copywriters. I may
write a hook that says something like
this. I fired a $6,000 a month client.
Here's what happened. Is that hook good
to golfers? No, they don't care. Is that
hook good to copyrighters? Yes, because
I wrote that hook and it was one of my
most viral tweets ever with over 1.2
million views on that one tweet because
it had that hook because most it is the
contrast of what most copywriters think.
They want to make money and get clients
and I wrote how I fired a client. And so
now the curiosity is through the roof.
They're like, "Why did this guy fire
this client?" It's irresistible if you
are the target market to read that and
not want to read what happens next. The
next one is pain. We've already talked
about pain, fear, desire. Here's how to
write a hook that has pain in it. Okay?
You have to touch a nerve, right? We
have to trigger the emotional nerve. I
wasted $5,000 on copywriting courses,
but this one book is a gold mine. So,
that's a good hook because a lot of
copywriters will spend a ton of money on
training, on writing courses, on
copywriting, on YouTube, all all these
things. That's a pain. They're like,
man, I don't want to spend that much
money to learn this skill, but this guy
has spent all that money, and he's
saying, "This book can help me avoid all
that pain." So, you're touching a nerve
of all that wasted money that they have.
So, that's pain. What about promise?
Okay, promise is the transformation that
you can provide your specific readers.
So again, if I'm talking to copywriters,
I may say something like, "Here's how to
fire your boss and start writing for
yourself online." They may get that and
then be like, "Oh my gosh, I cannot
stand working for my boss. 9-5 freaking
cubicle or these clients, these clients
are the worst. I cannot stand working
for them. I would love to fire them and
write for myself online." That is a
promise that creates a lot of excitement
because of this hook. When you read that
hook, you say that promise is big enough
to excite me or to piss me off, right?
in one of those ways. Remember, because
we're doing emotional triggers here,
too. Specificity is another little magic
sauce to get people to engage because
specificity increases believability. The
more vague you are, the less it engages
people's minds, the less they trust you.
So, if I say something like, "How I type
really fast," it's an okay headline. But
if I say how I type 156 words per
minute, it's a significantly more
engaging headline because now people are
interested. That specificity creates a
tangibility in people's minds and they
want to know, wow, how does this person
type 156 words per minute? Specificity
can help you do that. Another one is
simplicity. Simplicity is writing a
headline so simple that they
automatically start reading the next
line without even thinking about it.
Especially if your headline has some
sort of curiosity or intrigue right off
the bat. So like this headline, lies,
lies, lies, was written by Gary Benga.
It was so simple and it was huge bold
font. Imagine if I put that on a YouTube
thumbnail. Lies, lies, lies. People
would have curiosity. Who's lying? What
are they lying about? And it's so simple
that you naturally just start reading
the next line or that you naturally just
click the it's so simple you're like,
"Oh, let me just see really quick." It
is that simple. And so simplicity is a
magic little secret to writing
incredible hooks. Element number six,
proof might be the most powerful beyond
curiosity. Curiosity being the number
one most powerful element of a killer
headline. Proof may be the most powerful
element of sales. So, if you're trying
to sell something with a hook or sales
letter, an email, and you have proof in
your hook, you will naturally increase
the quality of reader, the quality of
buyer, and you will kill the skepticism,
which will increase your buyership. So,
if I write something like, "Watch this
2-hour copyrightiting crash course
written by a 15-year marketing executive
who sold $11 million worth of products."
Now, this video, which I'm obviously
talking about, this one right here,
written by me, a 15-year marketing
executive. I was a vice president at
multiple marketing agencies, and I've
sold over $11 million writing copy and
funnels. Now, I have some proof that I'm
freaking good at what I do. And so when
you're looking at all these videos and
you see that some Joe Schmo made a video
about a twohour copyrightiting crash
course and he looks like some
15-year-old kid versus you see a video
like this and you see a grown man with
proof that he knows what he's doing,
you're most likely going to click the
video of the person that has the proof
because it emphasizes that you don't
have to take the risk of going down the
rabbit hole and wasting your time. So
proof is an incredible hook element. Now
the last one is time frame. Time frame
increases people's perception and
curiosity to what the it is that you're
trying to solve for them. So like this
headline from John Cables, can you play
piano? Neither could I 3 months ago.
That is a perfect way of saying like,
oh, you have a problem of wanting to
play piano. What I'm about to show you
transformed me in 3 months. That's what
that subliminally says. Another way of
seeing this hook would be like how to
lose 15 pounds in 15 days. That's
probably not healthy, but it's a great
hook. or how to learn copywriting in two
hours. Right? I've used time frame.
People want to know what is the time
frame that they're investing. Now, some
things to caveat with this one is the
longer the time frame, the less
interesting it becomes. The faster the
time frame, the more interesting it
becomes because people want speed. But
the fastest time frame, the more
clickbaity it becomes. So, if I say I
will teach you to master copywriting in
12 months, you will look at me and say,
"That's not that interesting because
that's a really long time. It sounds
like a lot of work and I don't know if
I'm going to stick with it for that
long. If I say I'm going to teach you to
master copywriting in two weeks, you say
that's pretty cool. I think I could
learn that. It's not very intriguing. If
I say in 2 hours, you say, "Ooh, that
sounds pretty intriguing." 2 hours is
pretty pretty fast. That's kind of
crazy. How would I be able to do that?
It's challenging enough. But then if I
say master copywriting in two minutes,
your BS radar goes off. You're like,
"Okay, this guy's lying to me. Like, how
am I supposed to master something in two
minutes?" You see what I'm saying? The
time frame matters on creating the
tension and the curiosity of what to do
next. Too slow, you lost people. Too
fast, you lost people. Right at the
perfect tension of having something
that's challenging but intriguing at the
same time and believable. That's your
master time frame. Now, I'm going to
show you how we start stacking them.
Okay. Now, watch this headline. I wasted
$5,000 on AI courses, but this one
course made me $11,569
in 13 days. Look how many elements I
actually stacked in this hook.
Curiosity. What AI courses did he waste
money on? Pain. He wasted a lot of
money. Promise. I made x amount of
money. Specificity. Look at the numbers.
I didn't just say 12,000. I said 11,569.
I didn't say 2 weeks. I said 13 days. I
didn't say a bunch of money. I said 5
grand. Right? And then look at the
proof. The proof is I made the money.
And then I did all those things in just
17 words. So, we got 1 2 3 four five
hook elements in 17 words in this one
headline. So, a headline like this is
more than likely going to rip bananas
because I've used a bunch of elements to
increase the likelihood of it being a
killer hook. Now, one of the benefits
I'm going to give to you is that I have
studied thousands of some of the
greatest hooks ever written. And I've
packaged 101 of those greatest hooks
into a document called my 101 super
sticky hook templates. So, I've not only
packaged those hooks, I've actually
turned them into templates on how you
can reuse them. You can even take those
templates, upload them to your claw, to
your chat GPT, and use them to write
your own hooks with your own editing.
So, take those. There's a link in the
description below if you want to grab
those. You can have the most
attentiongrabbing persuasive hooks in
the world at your fingertips for free
just by making it this far into the
training. I told you I would pepper you
with gifts throughout the time. All
right, but we've still got a lot to
cover. So, let's go ahead and do that.
Let's go ahead and start talking about
how to write copy because a lot of
people think copywriting is just sales.
No, we're It says copywriter in the
freaking title. You are writing. And if
you can't write, if you don't know what
good writing looks like, then if you
prompt Claude, you won't know if it's
good or bad. If you write it yourself,
you won't know if it's good or bad. You
have to know what good writing looks
like. And so, I'm going to give you six
simple upgrades to sexify your writing.
All right, the first upgrade to your
writing is benefits over features. We
kind of touched on this a little bit
earlier where we're actually selling the
transformation where we talked about the
mattress. Remember, you don't sell the
mattress, you sell the best night of
sleep. That is what we're talking about.
The concept is nobody buys a drill, they
buy a hole, right? What does the drill
do? The drill gives them a hole. What
they want is the hole. They don't care
about the drill. They don't care about
how they get there. They care about the
actual result of the thing. And so, you
want to sell the benefits of buying your
thing, not the features. Let me give you
some examples. Like, a feature is losing
weight. You might write something like,
"I'm going to help you lose weight." But
what is the benefit of losing weight?
Well, the benefit is you get to go to
the pool and you're excited to take your
shirt off if you're a guy. Heads up.
[laughter] Or another one, I'm going to
sell you some 20 cold email templates.
Well, what do the 20 cold email
templates actually do? They help you
land high-paying clients in your sleep.
So, don't say, "Hey, here's 20 cold
email templates for $20." You could say,
"Land high-paying clients in your sleep
for $20." Do you see how much more
persuasive that is? Cuz what do they
want? They want the end result. They
don't want the cold email templates.
They don't care. They care about the
result. Or this one, here's an AI
writing template collection. What you're
actually selling is I'm going to help
you write your weekly newsletter in 30
minutes instead of four hours because
that's a big problem that people have.
So features describe, but benefits sell.
You want to stop describing your product
and you want to start selling it. Same
thing with email optins, YouTube titles,
all of that stuff. Simplify that tweak
in your writing and I guarantee your
writing will be more persuasive. What
about this one? Specificity. We already
talked this in the hooks, but when you
specify in your writing, it makes it
significantly better. Okay. So, what
does your brain picture more? If I say
the guy hopped in a car or the guy
hopped in a 69 red Camaro, which does
your brain visualize? Well, your brain
visualizes the 69 red Camaro. So, what
you're actually doing is you're painting
a picture in your reader's mind. And
when you could do that, it's sticky. The
writing becomes sticky. Let me show you
the specificity in action. Okay. So, if
you write something that's like, "Hey,
I'm going to help you wake up early." Or
what if you wrote, "I'm going to help
you wake up at 5:00 a.m. sharp, feeling
like the like you've slept for a week."
Okay. Which one is more enticing? Well,
the specificity that waking up at 5:00
a.m. sharp that I've slept for a week.
That feels that's more specific. That's
more enticing. What about this one? How
to start a side hustle or how I built a
$3,782
a month business in 90 days while
working my nineto-ive. Look at the
specificity of the number of how much
per month and how long 90 days while
doing what? Working a nineto-ive. So,
which one is more enticing? How to start
a side hustle or the specificity
headline? What about this one? I'm going
to help you get more subscribers or I'm
going to help you get a,000 email
subscribers in 3 weeks or less without
paying for a single ad. You see the
specificity? Numbers create this
specific claim in your headline and it
turns that claim into proof. So, when
you say, "Hey, I built a big side hustle
versus this is the exact amount in the
exact amount of days, and I'm going to
teach you how to do it." Right? You want
to continuously upgrade your writing by
making it more specific. Here's another
one. Speak to them, not to yourself.
Okay? The more times that you say, "Me
and I," the less enticing it is because
nobody cares about you. I'm sorry, but
nobody gives a crap about you unless you
can help them. They care about
themselves. Remember the life force 8
where we talked about the emotional of
survival and enjoyment of life survival
being the number one primary emotion of
people that survival means they're very
inward focused and so when you write
about yourself no one gives a crap they
want you to write towards them and so
when you start using words like you
instead of me and I your writing
instantly feels better it flows it is
much better so when you say we've been
in business for 20 years using premium
materials
You could rewrite it to say you get 20
years of hard one experience and
materials built to outlast everything
else you've tried. You make it about
them. Your materials isn't about you.
It's about them. They get the benefit of
it. Or this one. Our software has 50
powerful features. Rewrite it to say
you'll finish in an afternoon what used
to eat your entire week. That is a
benefit and it's about them. You see
that? What is the benefit that they get
from that software and how do you make
it about them? Okay. So, it's not our
software, it's their benefit, right?
Make everything about your reader.
Here's another upgrade is paint the
picture. Don't tell them the benefit of
your product. Drop them inside a visual,
visceral image of them using your
product, of them benefiting from your
product, okay? Of them benefiting from
watching your video. Make them feel like
it's already a memory before they
dropped in. Let me show you. So, if I
say something like, "Hey, I'm going to
help you make money online." Okay, no
one cares. What if I say, "Hey, imagine
sliding into your home office chair
tomorrow, opening up your laptop with a
fresh cup of espresso next to you,
writing on the internet, and there's no
boss, there's no Slack pings, there's no
revisions, and it's just you, and you
get to just do whatever you want to do."
Now, that's a lot of words, but which
one is more enticing? I'm going to help
you make money online. Or that image
that I just dropped you in where you now
paint the picture and you're like, "Oh
my goodness, that sounds incredible." Or
what about this one? This mattress has
me. We're selling a lot of mattresses
today. We're selling so many. If any of
you guys are selling mattresses, you're
welcome. This mattress has memory foam.
Okay. What about this way? Slip into the
softest foam mattress you've ever felt
and finally wake up with zero back pain.
Okay. Now I'm painting the picture where
I'm slipping in and I'm getting cozy and
I wake up and I'm like, "Man, I feel
good. Like that was amazing. I feel like
I slept for a week." Right? You're
painting that picture because if they
can feel it, they will buy it. They will
click. They will opt in. Now, upgrade
number five is making your writing
insanely simple. Complexity kills
clicks. It kills the scroll. Anything
that's complex, people are like, "Nah,
I'm good." It's overwhelming to see.
Remember, readers actually read with
their eyes. Okay? They read with their
eyes and they're like, "Nah, I'm not I'm
not reading all that, [laughter]
especially in the world that we live in
today. So, when you make something dead
simple like here, you increase the
retention of the reads." So, check this
out. Advanced coding secrets to
accelerate your programming education in
3 months or less. Okay. But what if we
said, "Learn to code in 12 weeks, even
if you're starting from zero." You see
how much more simple that is? It's so
simple that it's like, bam, I got it.
Master the fundamentals of personal
finance and wealth building for
long-term success. You've seen all that
bull crap on books and sales pages. But
what if you said, "Invest like the rich.
Start with $100."
How much simpler is that? So much
easier. Top 10 effective methods for
writing engaging content that resonates
with your target audience. Oh my gosh, I
want to throw up reading that. 10 ways
to write tweets that go viral without
guessing. So much simpler. Imagine every
word cost you a dollar and you have to
pay a dollar for every word. In fact,
imagine every syllable cost you a
dollar, right? Listen to that. Effective
method, writing, engaging, right? Like
how many syllables is that? 10 ways to
write tweets that go viral, right? Like
you see how much bam, poppy, choppy. So
simple to understand. What about this
one? Using bigger proof instead of a
bigger promise. Promises are like
balloons. The bigger that you make a
promise to someone, the more likely it
is to pop in their face because it's not
believable anymore. The bigger promise,
the bigger claim that you make, the more
proof you have to have to back it up,
right? So, let me show you how to do
that. Here's some examples. Here's the
most amazing memory foam pillow ever
made. That's a big promise. It's the
made. What if you said wake up without
neck pain used by 15,000 happy
customers? First off, that's already a
big claim that you're going to wake up
without neck pain. But I'm saying but
I'm backing it up with proof. 15,000
customers have bought this pillow, which
tells me something works. And so I'm not
saying it's the most amazing memory foam
pillow ever. I'm telling you you can
wake up without neck pain and 15,000
people will confirm it. What about this
one? Our coaching program will
absolutely transform your business.
First off, it's not specific at all, but
listen to this one. 14 out of our last
20 clients hit $10,000 a month within 90
days. That is proof. That is so much
more engaging than it will transform
your business. We're actually giving you
examples of how it's worked for other
people. That's way more engaging. What
about this one? The best productivity
app on the market. Says who? Rated
number one by 40,000 users. Average user
saves 6 hours a week. proof. That is
proof. So now people are way more
enticed. So don't inflate your promise.
Don't inflate your claim. Increase your
proof in your writing and it will be
more persuasive. And a quick recap.
Okay. So the six moves that you could do
to upgrade your writing is benefits over
features, specificity as the sauce.
Okay. You, not me. Paint the picture,
say it simply, and bigger proof, not
bigger promise. Those things will make
your writing so sexy, so easy to just
glide down that you're going to enjoy it
more and your readers are going to buy
more from it and click more into it. All
right, now let's dive into structure.
You have to be able to structure
your writing in a way that is
persuasive. This is something that most
people either really struggle with or
they underestimate. A lot of people come
into writing copy, writing articles,
creating YouTube videos, writing emails,
and all this stuff and they just start
writing shutt. But you may see all this
and you're like, well, where do I put
the proof and where do I put the promise
and where do I put the and how do I do
this? Blah blah blah. I'm going to tell
you, I'm going to show you proven
structures that have worked for decades
and decades and decades. They will
always work. And you can use these and
you can adapt them to tweets, to sales
letters, to emails, to whatever. And
these are the structures that you can
follow kind of like Lego blocks. put
these together, you can build something
amazing when you structure it the way
that I'm about to teach you. And it's
going to make writing so much simpler.
You're going to approach it with a heart
that's like, "Oh my gosh, this is way
better than I was doing it before." All
right, framework number one is a
framework called PAS, pass. Okay? It is
problem, agitate, solution. You want to
start by hooking someone with the
problem that they have. Then you want to
agitate that problem. You can agitate
with a line, with a story, long form,
whatever you want to do. You want to
agitate, then you want to introduce your
solution. I'm going to show you a short
form version, then I'm going to explain
how to do it in a long form version.
Let's say I were writing a tweet. Okay,
a tweet may read something like this. Do
you struggle to sleep? Okay, that is a
problem. Or, do you sleep less than 6
hours every night? Okay, that would be a
more specific problem. Somebody would
read that and they either have the
problem or they don't. They say, yes, I
sleep less than 6 hours every night. And
then I say something. Is it wrecking
your work, your mood, and your marriage?
You might read that and be like, "Oh my
gosh, it's agitating." They're starting
to think, "Yes, it is wrecking my mood.
It is hurting my marriage. It is hurting
my work." You've agitated the problem.
You stated the problem, then you made
the problem worse. It's also called
twisting the knife. You're twisting the
knife on their bleeding neck issue that
they have, and you're making it worse.
And then you're introducing
your fix. Our new mattress fixes this.
We're selling a We're selling a lot of
mattresses today. We should have got a
mattress sponsor for this video, which
is hilar. It's just so easy to sell. Um,
our new mattress fixes this or our new
mattress supported by 14,000 reviews
helps you sleep eight plus hours a
night. Trusted for the last 25 years.
Proof, curiosity, all that stuff. I've
injected that, right? And so now what I
did was I took the problem of my target
audience. I made it worse. And then I
introduced the solution. You could do
this in a tweet. You could do this in an
ad. If you're creating a meta ad, you
could do this and you can agitate. So
like if you get someone with a problem,
you can do a problems. Do you sleep less
than 6 hours a night? Does it take you
more than 10 minutes to fall asleep? Do
you continuously wake up time and time
again throughout the night? Problem.
Problem. Problem. Then you can agitate
it even more. It's wrecking your brain.
It's killing your mood. You're not able
to show up to work on time. You feel
sluggish while you're driving behind the
car. the more problem, the more pain,
the more agitation, the more likely
someone is to listen to an actual
solution because they want to solve the
problem. Then when you introduce it, our
mattresses have been organically woven
and blah blah blah and this and this.
And we've helped over 14,000 customers
and they've given dream sleep to these
types of executives and all kinds blah
blah blah. Right? You get where I'm
going with this. The structure is
problem agitate solution. You could do
it in an email. You could do it in an
ad. You could do it in a tweet. Short
long version. You just adjust the length
based on what you're writing. Right? If
it's a long sales page, then you're
going to spend a lot of time on the
problem, a lot of time on the agitation,
and a lot of time on the solution,
right? 33 33 33 if you want. In a tweet,
could be one sentence each. In an in a
meta ad, it could be a couple sentences
for the problem, couple sentences for
the agitation, couple sentences for the
solution. That's going to be a structure
that's a workhorse for you time and time
again. That's actually the first
structure that I would highly recommend
you use for ads and emails and sales
pages first because they're pain, fear,
all that stuff. Those are the most
emotional triggers. Now, here's another
one that you're going to love. This is a
classic from Gary Halper called ADA. ADA
stands for attention, interest, desire,
action. This is one that you could use
more often because if you use the pain
agitation solution over and over again
in emails or tweets or things like that,
you're just going to come off very
negative. You can use it over and over
for sales pages and ads, but in content
that you have to create on a fresh daily
basis, you might want to use something
like ADA. Attention, copywriting is
dead. Okay, that's a very simple
headline. Remember, I'm leaning into
simplicity there. I'm taking something
and I'm increasing the curiosity because
it's like, why is copywriting dead? It's
very simple, very curious, right? So,
we're writing hooks together. That's
what captures the attention. What is the
job of the hook? To get them to read the
next line. That's the job of the hook.
So if you're a copywriter, you read that
and you say, "I'm interested. I read the
next line." Then you increase the
interest. Now you've captured their
attention. Now you have to get their
interest. You have to say something
that's interesting enough to keep them
reading. The new Clawude Mythos 5 is
beating A-list copyriters left and
right. Ooh, that's very interesting. So
you've captured their attention with
copyrightiting is dead. Then you
explained why in a very interesting way.
Then the next thing is desire. Now you
want to give them something that they
already desire. You're channeling their
desire. And the prompts to use it are
insanely simple. I just increase your
desire because I'm saying it's beating
Claude Mythos 5 is beating A-list
copywriters and the prompts to use it
are so simple. So now you have a desire
for these prompts because I captured
your interest or I captured your
attention. I increased your interest.
Now I've tapped into your desire to get
that to be able to beat A-list
copywriters left and right. And the
action is comment mythos down below and
I'll send you the prompts. You could
blow up your entire Twitter account with
something like this. Ada is a great way
to get lead magnets out into the world
to grow your account to grow your
business to do all these sorts of
things. That's a banger structure. You
can do this in a long form format where
maybe you write a sales page where the
headline is copywriting is dead and then
the interest breaks down the claude
mythos 5. Last week claude mythos 5 was
introduced and it's beating copywriters
left and right. It beat this guy with
this kind of sales and it beat this guy
and blah blah blah and you could spend
80% of the sales page explaining the
interest. So you're writing long form
content with the interest and then you
increase the desire. And these prompts
I've packaged them. I've put them
together in this very easy to use prompt
template toolkit. And I've made it to
where you could just download it to your
computer. You can copy and paste the
prompts and you can start using it. And
then it says the action is if you would
like to buy these, you just click the
button down below, put in your credit
card. It's $55 and I'll send it to you
immediately. That is a more long form
version of this. So you see it's short,
it could be medium, it could be long,
but it's all the same structure.
Attention, interest, desire, action.
Now, I'm going to give you one more
structure proven that you're gonna
absolutely love. This one is called Bab.
Okay, before after bridge. I've used
this one quite a bit because it has this
story element to it that makes it even
stronger. And we know stories are 20
times more memorable than facts. I gave
you a story structure. Here's a
fantastic way to do a story element
structure that you're absolutely going
to love. It's before is 12 months ago I
was 286 pounds of pure fat but today I'm
168 pounds and jacked. Okay, before
after and then the bridge here are six
odd meals I ate to get shredded without
being hungry. That's the bridge. The
bridge is how the heck did this guy go
from 286 pounds of pure fat to 168 of
jacked? And then you insert this bridge
that connects that that makes them go
from A to B and increases the curiosity
for them to have the same
transformation. Another way that I might
write this is, hey, 5 years ago I
couldn't write Jack. Today I'm a number
one bestselling author. Here are 10
writing prompts that I use every single
day to transform my writing habits.
Okay, that's a before after bridge. You
could do this time and time again. A
year ago, I was sleeping three hours a
night. Today I'm sleeping nine hours a
night. Here's the mattress that I bought
to be able to get sleep instantly
without wrecking my habits. You know,
whatever it is, there's all kinds of
ways to do that. You could do this in
long form. 12 months ago, I was 286
pounds of pure fat. I was eating this. I
was doing that. I was out of shape. I
was sad. Blah blah blah blah blah blah.
And then all of a sudden, I was able to
start eating really odd meals that
helped me lose weight time and time
again. See, I'm telling it in long form.
That's what you can do by having the
opportunity to use the BAB framework
before, after bridge. You can put in a
tweet, email, ad, whatever. Those are
three structures that are absolutely
going to blow your copywriting world up
in the best way possible. You're going
to be able to absolutely dominate with
these three structures, which leads us
to the offer. Okay, we're almost getting
there. The offer is now the thing that's
going to sell the click, the action, the
purchase. We've talked about the
writing. We've talked about the
structure. We've talked about the
persuasion. We've talked about the
people. But we got to talk about the
offer. Cuz remember, 40 40 20. 40% is
the people. 40% is the offer. 20% is the
copy. It's finally time that we actually
get to the copy and start dominating so
I can show you how to create an
irresistible offer that people can't not
click. They can't not buy this thing.
Let's dive into what that looks like.
All right. The magic to making a
fantastic offer really comes down to one
concept. That concept is your offer has
to be so good that your reader would
feel stupid saying no. Now, I know
that's that's kind of easy to say, but
hard to do. So, I'm going to give you
the mechanisms, the the little unlocks,
the elements that make your offer so
good that your people would feel stupid
saying no. The first element to making a
killer offer, an irresistible offer, is
your core product. Remember how we
talked about earlier channeling desire,
pulling out pain and fear and solving
that stuff for people? Well, if you have
a core product that doesn't do either of
those things, then it doesn't matter
what you do. It doesn't matter what
timeline, what guarantee, what anything
like that. If you do those things and it
just it's not going to sell crap faster.
In fact, one time I was consulting a
business. They brought me on, paid me a
lot of money to help consult their
offer. And I said, "Listen, man. Here's
what's going to happen. you're going to
pay a lot of money for marketing and
it's actually just going to help you
tank your product faster cuz your
product sucks. And that was just real
honest advice. That's what marketing
does. It's either going to help you
explode something incredible or tank
something terrible. And so you need to
take a really hard look at the core
product that you're selling and saying,
"Does this channel the desire and solve
a fear, pain, or promise for my target
audience?" And then we could start
leveraging these other mechanisms. Okay.
And the next thing that we definitely
need to look into is a unique mechanism.
Okay, a unique mechanism is something
that you do that no one else does. I'll
give you an example. Like for me, I run
the club, the copy creator club and that
is the only club for copywriters and
creators to build their own clientless
online business. The fact that I could
say the only is what makes it a unique
mechanism. There are other copywriting
clubs on school on circle that either
teach you copywriting fundamentals or
they help you get clients. I don't
really do either of those things. What I
do is I give you a system and a
structure to fire your boss and sell
your own stuff online using writing in
the creator economy. No one else does
that. And because no one else does that,
I can position myself as the only person
that does this. Many other businesses
have this advantage that when they can
position themselves as the only like
Apple could say we're the only ones that
have AirDrop and because they have
AirDrop that's a feature that I really
really want and it saves me a lot of
time. They are the only ones that do
that. Amazon could easily say we're the
only people that have this amount of
stuff in one store. Again, you're
looking for the onlyies. I'm the only
banker that's going to tell you how the
inside banking world works so you could
profit from it or we're the only ones
that create a product using this
specific material. Again, the only being
your unique mechanism here. The next
element to your killer offer is
providing a specific result in a
specific time frame. So, let's say
you're a copywriter and you want to sell
meta ads or creative strategy to a
client. You could go to them and say, "I
will 3x your rorowass, your return on ad
spend in just 90 days or I'll give you
every single dollar that you pay me
back." Whoa, that's a super killer
offer. When you say something like that
and you said, "You're going to do this
in x amount of days or I'll give you
your money back." Cuz you're pairing it
with a guarantee, which is another
killer offer element that I'll dive into
a little bit later. You are making the
offer very irresistible. Now, remember a
specific claim, a specific results that
you're promising in a specific time
frame. Remember what I taught you
earlier. The bigger the claim, the
bigger the proof. Okay? You can't just
make a bigger claim. You can't make a
bigger promise without having bigger
proof. But the more proof you have, the
bigger claim you can make. Now, you say,
"Allan, I don't have any proof." Then
don't use this element. Don't use this
element for a killer offer. Use the
other ones. Or another thing that I like
to do is make the guarantee more insane.
I'll talk about that in just a second.
First, let's talk about price anchoring.
Okay, price anchoring is a phenomenal
way for you to increase your offer
desire. McDonald's did this wonderfully
years ago. They used to run billboards
making fun of Starbucks selling $4
coffees. They used to say something
like, "Why would you pay $4 when ours is
$1?" And they would have a cup of hot
steaming coffee on the billboard. And
what it does, it was price anchoring. It
was making people feel stupid. It was
like, "Why in the world would I pay $4
when I can go get a cup of coffee from
McDonald's for a dollar?" Now, obviously
you and I could say, "Oh, the quality,
the blah blah blah, but whatever." But
it was price anchoring. It was
brilliant. Using price anchoring to show
exactly, here's all the things you're
getting for this much. Hey, you're
getting this cup of coffee for a dollar
instead of $4. I've used price anchoring
again in Copy Creator Club where I said,
"You get live weekly coaching calls for
me. You get instant access to me. You
get masterclass training. You get a
monthly newsletter. You get a community.
You get all these things for $50
individually. it's going to cost you
this, this, and this, and this, and this
from all these other people, right? And
so, it shows you how much money you're
actually saving by doing it your way.
That's going to help create the
justifiable logic that remember, when
somebody buys your thing, they're going
to buy emotionally, but then they're
going to justify it to their wife.
They're going to justify it to their
spouse. And you want to be able to give
them that justifiable math. You want to
give them that tangibility with the
price. It's going to make the offer that
much more desirable. The next one is
urgency or scarcity. Why must they act
now? So urgency being the timeline,
scarcity being the amount of spots or
physical items or anything like that.
Combining these two becomes a
superkiller offer because it increases
the FOMO, the fear, fear of missing out.
If they can't get this now, they may
never get this. Some ways that you could
do this is with physical items, right?
Hey, we only have X amount in stock. Or
webinars, I only have a specific amount
of spots. Or a club. Hey, I'm capping
out the number of people able to join my
club so I can properly serve you guys.
Or hey, I have a deadline coming up. My
price is going to increase on my
community. It's going to go from $50 a
month to $100 a month. And it's going to
do that in the next 72 hours. If you
join before 72 hours, you get to $50 a
month. If you join after, the price goes
up. All of these things of urgency and
scarcity will help increase the offer
even better if it's real. If you're
obviously lying and trying to manipulate
people, it is not very helpful. One way
to kind of juice up the urgency scarcity
is to provide a reason why there is
scarcity. A reason why there is urgency.
Hey, I'm doubling the price to my club
because I can only serve X amount of
people. And if I can only serve X amount
of people, then I need the ability to
charge X amount of dollars so I can do
this full-time. That is a reason why I'm
increasing the price. Right? So now it's
more believable. You have a reason why.
Same thing with scarcity. Hey, we're
selling these. We've only got 10 of them
left because we're having problems with
shipments. We're not going to get more
shipments until January. And so if you
want to grab these 10, we're selling
them at this price and then we'll let
you know when we get more. Reason why
makes urgency and scarcity significantly
more believable and a killer offer. Two
more. The next one is guarantee. I
talked about this a little bit earlier.
If you pair specific result with
guarantee, it becomes incredibly more
powerful. I will get you this result in
this amount of days guaranteed or your
money back. One of my favorite
guarantees actually came from Ben
Settle. Ben Settle did this guarantee
where he was sending an offer via direct
mail for people to hop on a webinar for
his low stress trading company, which is
an options trading company. And his
offer was that you would come spend two
hours on a webinar with him and his team
if you're interested in options trading.
The webinar was free. And in fact, he
said that if you got to the end of the
webinar, you watched the entire two
hours and it did not benefit you
tremendously as he as in you regret
being on the two hours, then all you
have to do is email him and he would
send you $100 for wasting your time.
Now, that is an insanely good guarantee.
Hey, watch my webinar. If you're not
absolutely blown away at the end of the
two hours and you feel like I wasted
your time, email me. I'll send you $100.
So obviously naturally that got an
incredible response from the right
target audience and his low stress
trading company is one of his fastest
growing companies in his portfolio. In
fact, I believe it is his fastest
growing company in his portfolio because
that is an insanely good offer. Anytime
you can remove the risk from someone
enjoying your product or trying to take
advantage of your product will make it
more irresistible to buy because they
have they think what do I have to lose?
So, if I'm reaching out to a client and
I say, "Hey, I'm going to double your
email sales in 30 days or less. And if I
don't, I'll give you every dollar you
paid me and I'll send you a $300 bottle
of wine for wasting your time." Think
about that offer. How would a client be
able to resist that? To think, "Wow,
this guy's going to promise me double
sales and if he doesn't, he'll give me
all my money back and he's going to send
me a $300 bottle of wine." You're on.
You see what I'm talking about here?
That's the magic sauce. And the last one
is bonuses. Okay, perceived value in
bonuses increases the conversion rate of
your offer. I do this for my email list.
When you land on my website, I say,
"Hey, can I have your email address
really quick? I want to send you two
gifts worth $50. All you have to do is
put your email down below. I have two
books that I want to send you. They both
sell for $25 each on Amazon. They both
have five stars, and I'm going to send
them both to you absolutely free if you
put your email address in below." So,
the offer is you give me your email
address for free and I send you $50
worth of stuff. Tangible $50 worth of
stuff. People are paying $50 for this.
So, those bonuses to my offer make it
more enticing to join my email list.
Instead of saying, "Hey, would you join
my email list? I'll send you great
emails." I say, "Hey, join my email list
and I'll give you these two bonuses."
You could do the same thing with stuff
that you're selling. Hey, buy one jar of
honey. I'll give you two jars of honey.
Hey, buy one of my newsletter and I'll
actually send you three back issues for
free. buy one of my books, get two of my
other books. Anytime you do bonuses that
you can actually make a tangible offer
with, saying, "Hey, they're worth this
much on legit money, like other people
are paying for these things." You get
them for free. When you buy X by a
certain date, right? Give it a deadline.
When you buy X by a certain date, you're
going to get these things for free.
That's going to increase the conversion
rate, especially if the bonuses are
really congruent. So, let's say I
created a course on client acquisition.
Some bonuses I may say is, "Hey, you
could buy my course on getting clients
for copywriters. It's $99. And when you
buy it in the next 24 hours, you also
get my cold email templates to get
clients. You also get my client contract
so that way you can sign clients. And
you get my client ecosystem so that way
you can manage those clients in notion.
Do you see the congruency between the
bonuses and the offer? Bonuses are very
useful with the main offer, which makes
it more enticing because if they're
interested in the offer, they have the
pain and the desire. They're going to
want the bonuses." I wrote that one time
for a guitar company. When somebody
bought a guitar, I offered extra bonuses
like a case, strings, picks, leather
strap, all that stuff. I didn't offer
him, hey, when you buy this guitar, you
also get a saxophone. They're both in
the music world, but it's not congruent.
So, the bonuses have to make sense with
what you're getting. Those are the
unique mechanisms that we can use to
make a killer offer formula. And you can
use this one sentence to kind of help
guide your product launches to guide
your opt-ins. Where you could say, I
help golfers break 80 by using my triple
coil swing in 90 days, guaranteed. Okay?
I help men lose 20 pounds by eating my
honey recipes in 90 days, guaranteed.
Right? You start thinking through that
and then you stack the unique
mechanisms, right? the killer offer
formula to actually start selling your
stuff and some examples of what it may
look like. Okay, here's some crazy more
examples that aren't just selling stuff,
but like clicking the video, right? If I
want you to click my YouTube video, I
might make an offer that's like, "Hey,
here's a complete copywriting crash
course that gets you from zero to paid
writer, and I'm deleting it in 24 hours
cuz it's just too valuable." Now, this
video is going to stay up, but if I had
put that in the headline, oh my
goodness, somebody's like, "Look at that
urgency. Look at that deadline. Look at
that scarcity. This guy is going to
teach me all this and he's deleting it
in 24 hours. That would get a lot of
clicks. Or if I get you to join my email
list, I may say something like, "Hey,
get five cold email templates that
booked me 23 calls in one month and it
works even if you have a zero audience.
Just drop in your email and I'll send it
for free." That's an irresistible offer.
It got me this result. Here's the
tangible thing you're going to get me.
And all you need is my email in exchange
for that. Bonuses. That's a great one.
Or on the flip side, if I'm selling a
product, I may say, "Join, 1400
copywriters already inside proof. Get
lifetime access to my copywriting vault,
which is six courses, 200 templates,
weekly live breakdowns, perceived value,
bonuses, right? $197 today or $97 a
month forever. Wow, what an offer,
right? A one-time offer. 30-day money
back guarantee. Price doubles in 72
hours. We've stacked so many elements to
sell that." and you're reading that and
you're like, "Oh my goodness, I'm
drooling. This is incredible." Right? If
you are the target audience, and that's
because we used the killer offer
formula. Now, you know everything you
need to create incredible persuasive
action by writing copy. And we are
finally entering into the last step of
this masterclass training, and that is
to get paid. And what I'm going to do
for this last step is I'm going to show
you two paths that you could start
immediately after you close this
training to start making money writing.
All right, the first path to getting
paid with writing is to write for other
businesses. This is by far the simplest
path and probably the path that most of
you will take. It's most path that
almost every single writer wants to take
is they want to find clients. They want
to write for those clients and they want
to be able to make money writing for
those clients. So I'm going to show you
exactly how you can do that. how I've
done that before in the exact method
that I would recommend that you do that
right now. So you can take everything
that I taught you and actually go start
profiting and changing your life from
it. But remember, you do not sell
copywriting, okay? You sell growth, you
sell clicks, you sell sales, right?
Remember benefits over features. So when
you start navigating and having these
conversations with other businesses,
we're going to frame it in that sense.
We are not copyriters. That is the
unique mechanism that we are using to
sell these things, but we are going to
approach them from a business growth
perspective. Let me show you exactly how
to do that. So here's a road map. Okay,
this is the road map that I I'm
genuinely would tell myself. Hey man, if
you're going to start over, this is
exactly what you need to do. The first
is you need to start thinking in terms
of where are you the target market.
Remember cuz when we started this I said
you got to know your audience. You got
to be the market. Start thinking where
you are the target market. The best
place actually is what do you already
buy? What do you spend money on? So
let's say you spend a lot of money on
health supplements. Okay, that's a great
place to start. What have you already
spent a lot of money on? Or let's say
you buy a lot of golf gear or you buy a
lot of uh video games, you buy a lot of
books, you buy keyboards, you buy
technology. I'm looking around my
office. You buy guitars, you buy
journals, you buy all kinds of things,
and you start thinking, why did I buy
those things? What persuaded me to buy
those things? What problems did those
things solve for me? You can make a list
of all the brands that are in the market
for the thing that you are the target
market for. Let's say I'm building a
golf brand from scratch because I'm into
golf. I'm in the market. Understand
their pains, their hopes, desires. I
actually play. I've bought a lot of the
stuff. So, the first thing that I'm
going to do is I'm going to go make a
list of all of the brands in the golf
world. One of the best ways to do that
is you could go to Apollo.io and you
could just literally type golf and it'll
give you a bunch of the brands. It'll
give you their emails. It will give you
all the information you need to get
them. Or honestly, if you're in the
world, you know the brands. You can find
them on YouTube. You can find them on
Tik Tok. You could literally just have
Gemini, you could prompt Gemini, you
could prompt Claude said, "Give me 10
golf brands that I can reach out to for
email copywriting, for meta ads, for
sales pages, which by the way, those are
the three things that I would start with
by selling. Those are growth engines.
Ads, emails, and sales pages. A fourth
magnetic one could be social media if
you want to write on social media for
them, but it's not as high converting as
the other three. So now you have a list
of brands. Specifically, you want to
have a list of the brands that you've
bought from. Then the next step that you
want to do, you want to go and see the
stuff that they've already written. You
can actually go to Facebook ads library
and go see all the ads they're already
running on Meta. Or you can opt into
their email list. You can go to their
website. You can join their email list
and you can start reading their emails.
See what their welcome sequence is like.
Go buy a product. Remember, be a secret
shopper and actually go through their
post purchase sequence and see how
they're selling you there. Go to all
their landing pages and see how they're
selling their products. And then I want
you to screenshot and copy everything
that they've written. And I want you to
rewrite it using the training that I've
given you here. Read all their copy and
say, "Wow, this doesn't have any proof.
This doesn't have a unique mechanism.
There's no good story in these emails."
Well, we're going to have to tell a
better story. Right? You start injecting
all the things, curiosity, pain, fear,
emotional selling, logistical, price
justification. You start doing all these
things and you rewrite their ad copy.
You rewrite their emails. You rewrite
their sales landing pages. Then you put
all the before and after in some sort of
document, a Google doc, a notion
document, something like that. You can
even have Claw Design make it very
beautiful for you. And then you reach
out to them by their email. Remember,
cuz you can go to Apollo.io. You could
grab the email, the marketing director's
email of that company, and you could
send that marketing director a cold
email. And it's a very personalized
email. It's not like, "Hey, do you have
10 minutes to talk?" Like you don't send
it to a thousand people. You send it,
"Hey, my name's Allan. Heads up. I've
bought your hats before. I love your
hats. I wear them on the golf course all
the time. When I bought your hat, I got
your welcome sequence. When I got your
welcome sequence, I wanted to let you
know that you're missing quite a few
elements that could actually help you
sell quite a few more hats. In fact, I
took your welcome sequence and I rewrote
it." What I want you to do is this. And
then you move to step number four is you
make them a killer offer they can't
refuse. Okay? make them a killer offer
where you say, "I would love for you to
AB test your email against my email. I
rewrote the email. You can go into
Clavio right now and AB test it. All you
have to do is copy and paste the email
that I wrote and if my email outsells
your email, I will write you three more
emails for free so you could see that it
wasn't a spoof and that I can outsell
all of your emails. Once my email
outsells all of your emails, you could
see that I'm legit. And if we want, we
could discuss partnering together for me
to manage all of your email campaigns.
And if my emails don't outsell your
emails, then I will send you a $100 gift
card to get any bottle of wine that you
want for free as an apology for wasting
your time. Now, that's an offer that
they can't refuse. You rewrote it. You
personalized it. You're a customer.
They're going to AB test it. you're
going to knock the socks off cuz 99% of
brands don't know what the heck they're
doing. Especially if you're starting to
inject the copyrightiting tactics that I
wrote for you. I mean, it literally
could be as simple as you could just
take the deck that I'm teaching you,
upload it to Claude, upload their copy
to Claude and say, "Tell me the missing
elements that Master Sensei Allan Dragu
would have written in this. Find those
missing elements for me so I can rewrite
this copy or have Claude rewrite it."
And then you tweak it. You adjust it.
You make it more fun. You make it more
enticing. and I guarantee it's already
going to be a hundred times better than
what they're already writing. And with
the offer that you're writing it for
free and you're offering a free bottle
of wine or whatever it is, if you're
wasting their time, which by the way 99%
of brands will never take you up on. But
the best part is when when you do get
the results, they do take you up on it.
You absolutely smash it. And the next
part is part five where you actually
turn it into a case study. And a case
study is simply before me it was this.
After me it's this. And it's the before
after bridge. Before me, they were
making 10 grand a month. After me,
they're making 23 grand a month. Here's
exactly what I did to help this brand
make double their monthly revenue. You
make as many case studies as possible
with their email, with their ads,
whatever you're doing. And then once you
have that case study, you reach out to
your contact and you say, "Hey, John,
thank you so much for allowing me to
work on this. Here's some here's a case
study that shows the great success that
we've had over the last few months. By
any chance, do you know one other brand
that would benefit from my services to
be able to serve their email, to be able
to serve their meta ads, to be able to
serve their landing pages? I would
really appreciate if you could connect
me so I can help them do the same thing
that we did for you. And chances are,
they're going to do one of three things.
They're either going to say, "I don't
know anybody right now, but I uh, you
know, if I think of somebody, blah,
blah, blah." And then you just keep
asking for referrals once a month, once
every month. Or they're going to say,
"Hey, I actually do know a guy. He sells
perfumes. Can you sell perfume?"
Absolutely. Right. Absolutely you could
do that. Or three, they'll say like,
"Hey, actually, I really enjoy what you
did with the meta ads. Would you do
emails for us?" "Hey, I love what you
did with the emails. Will you do sales
pages for us?" "Hey, I love what you did
with the sales pages. Would you write
our social content?" And so, either way,
it's going to be a win-win. That is the
exact process that I would do to go from
being a nobody to knowing your market to
reaching out to booking clients to
making a killer offer and actually
getting more referrals and clients. I
would do that. But on the flip side,
there's an alternative path that most
people are either unaware of or they
just don't know how to navigate. And
that second path is what I call the copy
creator path. I've built literally an
entire school community around this. And
I'm going to teach you the fundamentals
right now because chances are you may be
looking at this whole like getting a
client thing and you're like, "Oh my
gosh, I don't know if this is going to
work for me. Nobody's going to hire me.
I'm scared to talk to clients. I don't
want to get on the phone. What if they
do take me up on that irresistible offer
and now I'm sending these guys wine?
What if I fail? All these things. The
better path that I actually believe in,
this is the path that I've built for
myself. I actually no longer do client
work. What I do is I write for myself.
And the way that I write for myself and
make money writing online is off this
framework that I've built called the ARM
framework. ARM stands for audience
relationship money. This is the exact
framework that I actually recommend
everyone start and go down. Only caveat
to this framework is that it is a much
slower, much more patient process than
getting a client. Like if you get a
client, you can work really, really hard
for two to three months to go get a
client and suddenly you're making two
grand a month, three grand a month. So
you're making good money with the ARM
framework building it for yourself. It's
more like investing. It could take a
year or two to start getting some very
fruitful income, but that's what
investing is like. And the flip side of
investment is you build compound
interest in your investment. So you
building your own business is going to
be far more valuable in the next two,
three, four, five years than you still
working for someone else's business
because eventually you're going to get
tired of trading your time for money.
Hey, write me more emails to make more
money. Hey, spend more time on my
business for you to get more money and
then they can fire you and then you lose
the money. But if you own your own
business and you actually build a
leveragebased business like I'm about to
show you, then you can do it today and
it doesn't cost you anything. You don't
need anyone's permission and you don't
have to chase a client and you can write
and learn and iterate and actually build
your own business that lives and
compounds over time. So let me show you
what that looks like. So audience
audience is building people around you.
Okay, so this is more like a personal
brand writing online. The best way and
place that I do this is social media.
That's why one of the reasons I create
YouTube content is because I can build
an audience around what my mission is in
life, which is the best way to build an
audience. The best way to build an
audience is to pick a mission that
you're trying to achieve and then
document that mission on the internet.
Okay. So, the mission that I'm on right
now is I help writers write their way to
autonomy. I want to help copywriters,
creators be able to live in a world
where they decide what they do, when
they do it, how they do it, and how much
they make doing it. A fully autonomous
lifestyle where they don't have to drive
to a cubicle, work a nineto-ive job, or
report to someone they hate working for.
That's the old path. So, I'm on a
mission to create an autonomous
lifestyle for as many writers as
possible, which is exactly why I'm
teaching you this framework. And because
I'm on that mission, I'm documenting
everything to help you do that. Learning
copywriting is a stepping stone towards
that mission. If I can teach you
copywriting, I could teach you one of
the greatest assets ever to build an
audience and sell your own stuff and
become fully autonomous. So, this video
is a stepping stone towards that
mission. You do the same thing. What is
the mission that you're on? Maybe you're
on a mission to get into a specific
college and you're documenting your
journey of how to get into Stanford or
Harvard or Cambridge. Or maybe you're on
a mission to be a scratch golfer and to
dominate the pro tour and you're
documenting everything you learn to hit
line drives, chip and putt and be
better. Or maybe you're on a mission to
get absolutely jacked and you're
documenting everything you're learning
to lose weight and add protein and gain
muscle. Pick the mission that you're on,
solve problems towards that mission, and
then you package those problems into
solutions that you sell. But there's a
big caveat to building an audience
online. Building an audience online on
social media, on YouTube, on Twitter, or
anything like that is what I would
consider rented land. This is land
that's owned by someone else. Google
owns YouTube, right? Mark Zuckerberg
owns Meta. Elon owns Twitter. And the
problem with social media platforms is
that they actually don't give you direct
communication with your audience, with
the people that you're building a
relationship with. Because Elon can come
in and change the Twitter algorithm
tomorrow and you no longer get the reach
that you used to get. or Google could
completely nerf the YouTube algorithm
and all my videos die. But the thing
that has been around for decades and has
no algorithm is email. So your goal is
when you build an audience on YouTube,
on Twitter, on LinkedIn, on whatever,
you can bribe those people with a killer
offer to join your email list. Once you
own a piece of your audience's
information, you could communicate with
them directly and actually build a
deeper relationship because they'll hear
from you in a personalized manner. Email
is very personalized. It's very
one-on-one. Right? When this video is on
YouTube, you know that it has hundreds
of views, thousands of views, whatever
it has. But when you get an email, you
get an email to yourself. It's from me
to you. And you read it and it feels
like a one-on-one relationship. And you
do the same for your readers. You can
send them emails and you tell them
deeper stories of you pursuing your
mission. Remember, you're on a mission
to get into that college. You're on a
mission to be a scratch golfer. You are
on a mission and you're talking about
that mission on a deeper level with
stories. In fact, I'm going to put a
card above. I I go into a whole deep
dive on how to write storydriven emails
that help people build relationships and
buy from you. And the thing that you do
in email more than anything else is you
make killer offers to increase your
income, to increase the money that you
make. Because what you're doing is
you're serving those people. You are on
a mission and they are attracted to you
because you're on that mission. Chances
are they're on that mission. They're
trying to get into that college. They're
trying to be a scratch golfer. And so
your job while you're on the mission is
to package the solution to the problems
you solve. One of the best ways that you
can do that is by selling one of these
three products. Okay? You can either
sell a community like I do. I run a
school community to help you build your
own clientless writing business using
the ARM framework. Or you could sell a
paid newsletter like on Substack or on
Kit. Or you could sell a cohort, which
is like a collaborated thing for a
certain period of time. Let's say we go
through a 21-day sprint on building a
YouTube channel or we go through a
21-day sprint of writing your first
book. These are great ways for you to
sell offers to your email list. The
reason I like those three more than like
courses or or PDF trainings or anything
like that is because people want to do
things with people. And I've seen these
sell significantly more. Like a
community on school is obviously very
collaborative. A newsletter on Substack
has a community feature to it. So you
get the information, but you're also
part of the group chat on Substack. A
cohort, you're doing it together.
Anything where you can have a network
effect and people actually collaborate
together and move towards the journey
together, you'll be able to sell a lot
more of those and you'll actually get a
lot better results because people will
be more interactive. Not to mention a
community and newsletter are recurring
revenue. So instead of selling $5,000 of
product one time, I'd rather build a
business that makes a,000 2,000 5,000
$10,000 worth of money on a recurring
basis knowing that it's coming in next
month and the month after and the month
after and the month after. But the
primary basis of what you sell is you
sell to solve. Okay? Everything that you
sell should help someone solve a problem
so they can overcome the obstacles on
the way to their mission. That's all
you're doing is I'm trying to achieve
this. On the way there, there's a bunch
of obstacles and problems. I'm going to
overcome them. I'm going to package how
I overcame them and I'm going to sell
them to the people behind me who are
also trying to accomplish that same
mission and solve those same problems.
Don't worry about picking a niche and a
brand and all that. That crap is bull
crap. You are on a mission solving a
problem. You're documenting your mission
on social media. You're bribing them to
your email list. You're telling very
story driven emails and making an offer
to sell your thing. And if I were you, I
would pick path two to building your own
business. Cuz you don't need anyone's
permission to start writing on Twitter.
You don't need anyone's permission to
build your email list. You don't need
anyone's permission to make your own
products. So, you don't need anyone. You
don't You could do it today. You could
open up a Twitter account, an email, and
a Gumroad account today. And you start
pumping. You start writing tweets. You
start learning copy. You start putting
it out there. You don't have to reach
out to clients. You don't have to get
their approval. You don't have to beg
for them to pay you. You start doing
your thing today. Will you make money
today? Probably not. Which really wraps
us up. You know, the whole game. The
whole game is no hook, trigger, right?
Structure, offer, get paid. That is the
whole game. You understand the
foundation of everything that I've
taught you. I hope this was immensely
helpful. Don't forget, don't forget I've
got some extra goodies to help you from
this. We've got the AI market research
prompts, okay? We've got the 101 hook
templates and we've got the 42 advanced
copyrightiting secrets all in the link
in the description below. I've got the
whole slide deck for everything that we
went through today if you want to use it
to get going. I know I've mentioned it a
couple times. uh you're more than
welcome to check out copycreatorclub.com
that if you are interested in building a
client list-based writing business where
you're not working for clients but
you're writing for yourself you're
writing online you're you're writing
emails you're selling your own stuff
fantastic check out copycreatorclub.com
if that's helpful for you thank you so
much for watching please take two
seconds to like it you've made it this
far the least you can do is hit like
subscribe to the channel tell me that
you loved it that you want more content
like this tells YouTube algorithms that
uh you want more valuable stuff like
this in your world and it tells me to go
ahead and create more stuff. This stuff
takes weeks. I spent weeks putting this
course and training together. So, it
would mean a lot if you could just like
and subscribe. I appreciate it. Thank
you so much. And I will catch you on the
next one.